The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons License.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JOE LEAVITT: Good afternoon.
My name is Joe Leavitt.
My group members are Ben Ayton,
Jess Noss, Erlend Harbitz,
Jake Barnwell, and
Sam Pinto, and we're
going to introduce you to
the topic incremental path
planning.
Listed on screen are just
some of the references
we used in putting
together this lecture.
The top three are the
main references we used
in developing our material
on the D* Lite algorithm,
but also take note of
the bottom reference,
which is a paper done within
Professor William's group here
at MIT.
It talks about
all-pairs, shortest paths
incremental search method.
So if you're interested
in more incremental search
methods than those we're
going to talk about today,
please get into this.
Especially if you're going
to go ahead and do our P set,
these references will
be very helpful to you.
So today, we're going
to first Monday problem,
then we're going to introduce
the idea of incremental search.
Then we're going to go
into detail on the D* Lite
algorithm, which is type of
incremental path planning,
an algorithm used for
run through an
example of D* Lite,
talk about when it is good to
use incremental path planning
when other path planners
might be better,
and then I'll go into
some algorithm extensions
and related topics, and
some applications in mobile
robotics.
So in order to
motivate the problem,
we're going to use a robot
living in a grid world.
It's at a start location trying
to get to a goal location.
It can move up, down, left,
or right, or diagonally.
And it can only see the
eight cells around it,
as it's moving through
this grid world.
And we're going to give some
pretty fine map of the world.
This is a map that has the
world before it starts moving.
And it's possibly moving
through some of these,
new obstacles could appear,
or obstacles could go away.
And the idea is that it's
going to make observations
as it's moving to this
world and update its plane
to get to the goal based on what
it sees as it's moving along.
So I must correct myself.
The map that you're
seeing now is the map
that the robot
has ahead of time.
The previous map is what
the environment actually
looks like.
So as it starts
moving, it's going
to make a plan to get from
the start to the goal,
and that's what
we want it to do.
And it's going to move
to the next position
and then realize that there's
an obstacle in the path
that it previously
planned, and now it
must replan in order to find
a valid path to the goal.
And so now, it
replans, and continues
to move on the new plan, and
now it finds another obstacle
that it has to replan around,
and it does the same thing.
And then it continues
to walk through
until it gets to a
point where we have
a change in the environment.
The change is represented
by these two cells
going black here, and
now its original plane
is no longer valid again.
And what we want it
to do is to replan
to find a new valid
optimal path to the goal.
This is just showing here what
happened to our environment.
And then the robot
replans and continues
to march towards
the goal So this
is the behavior we want
from a mobile robot,
whether it's a two-dimensional
path-planning problem,
or we're talking about
multi-dimensional robot arms,
planning, working with
humans on a manufacturing
environment, or an
activity-planning process.
The idea is that
we want the robot
to be able to account for
new obstacles or changes
in its representation
of the environment
and continue to plan on the
fly quickly and optimally.
So there's methods
that accomplish this.
One method used to
in path planning
is rapidly exploring
random trees, or RRTs.
RRTs are basically
going to plan, replan,
on every time step based on
changes in the environment.
And one problem in
my experience here,
though, is that RRTs are
suboptimal, even though fast.
See, here you see the robot
has come up with a plan.
It's seeing new obstacles,
the table in front of it.
The coffee cup.
And its planning for those
things, so the plan it came up
with is clearly not optimal.
So we can perform some
additional computation.
We can use a method that
builds upon the RRT, RRT*,
that it finds an optimal path,
but that requires a pretty
significant amount of
offline computation time,
and then you can accomplish
something that looks a little
more normal.
Again, we have to
allow the robot
to perform a lot of the
computation off-line.
So how do we accomplish
what we want to?
We want to compute quickly.
We want to compute
optimally, and then
have the robot continue
to move as it's
received new information
coming to the environment.
Some problems we're
facing, there's
changing environmental
conditions.
There's sensor limitations.
You might not be able
to see everything
in the environment
around you, and then we
have limited computation time.
And the solution that
we're going to explore here
is to reuse that from
the previous search,
in order to speed up
the search process,
and continue to plan optimally.
And the method we're going
to use to accomplish this
is incremental search.
So now, we're going
to talk about what
incremental search means.
First to show you kind of how
powerful incremental search can
be, this is one example of
an incremental search method,
incremental all-pairs
shortest paths,
which allows you to online
compute paths between any start
and goal location.
The idea is that you have
a robot that's trying
to move around one obstacle.
That's what you see in the
upper sequence of events there.
And another obstacle
is added, and now it
has to plan around
this new obstacle.
In using this algorithm, you
have a significant increase
in performance and
computation time
using the all-pairs shortest
paths versus an RRT.
RRT can act as another
version of an RRT,
where you're planning basically
from both the goal and start
and connecting your paths.
It's on the order of
what you get with RRT,
but this RRT connect
algorithm doesn't give you
an optimal result.
And then it's even
fast than another
algorithm probablistic road
mapping, where you're randomly
sampling the environment,
and connecting points
to produce a path.
So the idea here is
that we can really
leverage this idea of reusing
results from previous searches
to accomplish fast
replanning online.
So the whole idea of
incremental search
is that we're going to
form a normal graph search,
just like anybody's used to.
And then we're going to
repeat as the robot moves
through the environment, or
you're executing your plan,
you're going to execute
the next point in the plan,
or the next action in the plan.
We're going to receive
changes from the environment,
either through our sensors or
information from the outside.
And then we're going
to use that information
to update our previous search
results instead of completely
replanning, and then
continue to form that loop,
until you reach your goal.
So before we get into too many
of the details of how we're
going to accomplish
this, first, we
want to review the
graph search problem.
So in graph search, you
have a graph consisting
of vertices or nodes.
We're going to use nodes
throughout this lecture
to talk about the vertices
or nodes in the graph that
are connected by edges.
And then, there's an
edge weighting function
that describes the cost going
from one node to another.
And then, a heuristic
function is an estimate
of the cost to get from a
current node to the goal node.
And then we a start
vertex and a gold vertex.
In the graph search
problem, we're
also going to have this idea
of a g value, or a cost so far.
We're going to use term g
value, which is essentially
the cost that it's taken to
get to some predecessor node,
plus the cost of the node that
you're actually expanding.
So you would have this
W start to S1 cost
to get from start to S1.
And then the g value
for S goal would
be the weight from S1 of the
goal plus the S1's g value.
Yes, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: What is W?
JOE LEAVITT: W is the
weighting function
that I talked about
previously here.
So the weighting function
describes the cost
to get from one node to another
along any edge in a graph.
And then we'd use
those waiting functions
to develop the idea
of the G value.
So W is just the edge cost.
And then our
heuristic value, like,
we use our heuristic function
to establish a heuristic
value from one goal to
another, and we're going
to call that our h value, or h.
And then the total estimated
cost to get from a node
that we're currently
expanding in a graph search
is f, which is your cost so far,
plus your estimated cost to go.
I think I might have
messed that up in there.
Call g value associated
cost so far, not cost to go,
and then h is an
estimate of cost to go.
So in order to reason about
a real-world environment,
we first have to
take that environment
and convert it to a graph,
so we can form graph search,
and then do everything
we're talking about.
Some of the examples,
we're going to talk about,
and some of the ones we've
already talked about,
we're using this
notion of a grid world.
You can have a four
connected graph
or a grid, where a robot can
move up, down, left, or right,
basically in x or y directions,
or an eight connected graph,
where you can also move
along the diagonals.
And then had here,
we just showed
the graphs associated
with those, with the nodes
and edges.
And then you would have an
associated admissible heuristic
with those if you're going
to form a heuristic search.
So just know up front
that any time we're
moving from a real
world environment,
that we're trying to reason
about these search methods,
we have to develop
an associated graph.
And one more thing that
is important as far
as understanding
incremental searches,
is the notion or
idea of relaxation.
We're going use
Dijkstra's algorithm.
Everybody here familiar
with Dijkstra's algorithm,
I'm assuming, in the past.
We're going to use
Dijkstra's algorithm
to kind of illustrate
the idea of relaxation
and remind everybody of what
that means, because it's
an important concept
when we're talking
about incremental
search algorithms.
So essentially, in
Dijkstra's algorithm,
it's a single source, shortest
path algorithm, a best
first search.
So we're going to make eight
expanding nodes according
to their best g
value, or cost so far.
And we have our start
node initialized
to zero cost so far,
because at your start,
haven't accrued any cost.
And then, every
other node is going
to be initialized to infinity.
And the idea is we're
going to find the shortest
distance to all
of the other nodes
by relaxing the cost to
those nodes from infinity
down to their actual shortest
or lowest cost value.
So we start by expanding
the start node,
and then you find
the cost so far
to each of the children
nodes of the start node.
So you have an edge way
to one, and so the node
on the bottom as a value of 1.
Similarly for the middle node
at 5, and the top node for 3.
Now, the next node
we're going to expand,
can anybody tell me
what the next node
we're going to expand based on
performing best first search
here using cost so far?
AUDIENCE: The 1?
1?
JOE LEAVITT: Yes.
So the node labeled 1 here,
that has a g value of 1
is the lowest out of 1,
3, and 5, and infinity.
So we're going to go
ahead and expand 1 next.
And now, we find that using
this value of 1 plus 3
equals 4, which is less
than what we previously
had here as 4.
So now the center node has
been relaxed from a value of 5
down to 4.
So now the shortest path we
found to the center node is 4.
And we're going to
continue to perform this
by going through each node
in order of the lowest cost.
And similarly, you
saw how the top node
was relaxed to 6 by going
through 1, 3, and 2, where
as previously, it had a
lowest cost of 7 going
through 3 and 4.
And if we format
through the whole graph
until all nodes have
been unexpanded,
then we've relaxed
every node in the graph
to its shortest path value.
And then, we can just
do a greedy search
from a chosen goal node,
back through the graph
to find shortest path.
AUDIENCE: Is the term
relaxation standard?
Because the fact that you're
bringing numbers from infinity
double to small
value sounds more
like tightening as
opposed to relaxation.
So I was just wondering
if people use it
as like, a standard--
JOE LEAVITT: I'm not sure
if it is in all areas,
but I have seen it
in multiple places.
When you're talking
about graph search,
specifically with respect
to Dijkstra's algorithm,
that is where the term
relaxation is used.
And we're going to use
that as we go throughout
and talk about
incremental search.
We're kind of repairing the
results because of new edge
weights and things like that.
We're going to figure
out which nodes
we have to relax back down
to their shortest value
to be able to find
the new shortest path.
So that's the term
we're going to use here
if it's not used universally.
I can't say for certain.
But we will use relaxation
to talk about reducing--
it's kind of related to--
think about like,
a tension spring.
As you reduce the
constraints on it,
it'll slowly relax to its
completely relaxed position.
That's kind of the idea here.
So now that we have talked
about the ideas of relaxation
and graph search, how
do we reuse the results
from a previous search
in a new search field
to employ an incremental
search method
where you have done a search,
you found the shortest path,
and now, you had some
changes to your graph,
and you want to use your
previous results to come up
with your new shortest path.
So the way we're
going to do that,
is we're going to store
our optimal results
from a previous search.
This can be done in
a number of ways.
It's going to depend
on the algorithm.
But you can soar like,
a list of shortest paths
as an incremental all-pairs
shortest paths problem.
The one we're going to talk
most about is storing g values,
and that's what's done
in a D* Lite algorithm,
where you're finding the
shortest distance from any
given node that you've
expanded so far in your search
to the goal node.
And then, you'll use that
data to find out, find
the shortest path.
And then when you go to
perform your next iteration,
you'll look for
inconsistencies in that graph.
And then in order to
find a new shortest path,
we'll leverage that previous
data and the inconsistencies
for relaxations to come up
with a new optimal solution.
And that's all
we're showing here.
On the right side of
these two graphics is
you have the initial search.
You have an obstacle that
is now in a place that
was wasn't there
previously, which
causes you to update edge
weights in the graph associated
with this grid world.
And then using
these values which
represent the g values
in the graph search,
you only update
the ones you need
to update to find
a new optimal path.
And so completely
reperforming our search.
So what incremental
search methods
exist, now that we've kind
of talked about what they are
and what we can do with them?
So the whole idea
of this slide here
is to show you that
incremental search can
be used across many domains.
It's not just specific
to path planning.
It's used in temporal
planning to determine
temporal consistency.
It can be used propositional
satisfiability.
Instead of every time you're
updating another algorithm,
you can use your
previous results.
And the one we're going to
focus on today is D* Lite,
which is specific to
mobile and robots.
But the ideas and concepts
we're going to talk about there
are applicable
elsewhere, and you
can use to help you learn
about and expand your knowledge
in other incremental search.
So the D* incremental
path planning approach.
The whole idea behind
it is that we're
going to take the idea
of incremental search
that we just talked
it about, and we're
going to combine it with
heuristic search, which
is an optimal solution.
And the idea is
that two things are
orthogonal so we
can combine them,
and then we can form
efficient incremental path
planning, getting both
an optimal result,
and quickly getting
a new path when
things change in the
environment without having
to completely replan.
And so what that
looks like, when
we have a grid world, which is
shown in four instances here up
on the board, and we're trying
to plan from a start node
to a goal node, and showing
each of these sections.
And in the upper left or
on the left axis, we have--
whether we're performing
a complete search
or an incremental search.
And on the horizontal
axis, whether it's
an uninformed search
or a heuristic search.
So the upper left is
a complete search,
just using best-first
search and no heuristics.
And what it's showing is all
the nodes that are expanded,
and trying to find a path
from the start to the goal.
In the upper right is
a heuristic search, A*.
Employing the heuristic,
we're able to collapse
the number of nodes
expanded by quite a bit.
In the bottom left is an
incremental search method
that's using uninformed
search or best-first
search as an underlying
search algorithm,
so it's going to expand the same
nodes as the best-first search.
And then in the bottom
right, you see an incremental
heuristic search, the lifelong
planning A* algorithm,
which is kind of the baseline
for the D* Lite we're going
to talk about, that the initial
search will expand the same
nodes as the heuristic search,
since it's using A* as its
baseline.
So now let's say
the robot moves.
We get an update
to the environment.
There's a bunch
of changed edges.
And now best-first
search, as you can see,
is going to have to expand
pretty much the same number,
if not more nodes, then
our previous search.
And A* also is going to expand
about the same number of nodes
as it did previously.
The incremental search method
using best-first search,
by using previous results,
reduces significantly
the number of nodes that
needs to be expanded.
And then, lifelong planning
A*, the incremental search plus
the heuristic search, reduces
that number by even more.
Even when there's quite a few
changes in the environment,
you have very few
nodes that you need
to expand on the
next search in order
to find a new optimal path.
With that, I'll turn it over to
Ben to talk about the D* Lite
algorithm.
BEN AYTON: Thanks.
So I'll be walking you through
the D* Light algorithm today.
Now as we're emphasizing,
the D* Lite is not the only
incremental algorithm, as
we mentioned previously.
But it is a widely used
incremental algorithm,
and you'll see it's quite
efficient in what it does.
D* Lite is an algorithm that
searches from a single start
node to a single goal node.
But as we see changes occur
in the path along the way,
we'll adjust that.
So it's nice to think about
D* Lite from two perspectives.
One is to think about it as a
modification of the principle
space.
Now, you'll see that D* Lite
in its first iteration or its
first run through before any
modifications behaves very
similar to A*, and that's where
it's nice to keep that main
model in mind.
And you'll see that in
an example further along.
The second perspective to look
at A* is from the perspective
of Dijkstra's algorithm,
from which we see many
of the principles of relaxation
that we covered beforehand.
From this perspective, we see
that when we do reparations
to the graph or changes to the
graph, our methods of repairs
the graph is essentially to
relax down our changed edge
weights until they
reach their truth.
Now, where we differ from
Dijkstra's algorithm with
something like D* Lite is
selecting only the nodes that
we want to hit efficiently.
So whereas Dijkstra's algorithm
tried to fit the entire graph,
we only want to travel
from a single start node
to a single goal node.
And so D* Lite behaves like
Dijkstra's, but a guided
Dijkstra's.
So I'd like to just remind you
of several concepts from A*
first, because it's easier to
introduce them in that context.
And then we'll modify
them a little bit.
So Joe mentioned
before that for A*,
we're searching from a
start node to a goal node.
We're sorting the
nodes in our queue
by total cost, which is the sum
of what we're calling g, which
are costs to get
to a single node,
and our heuristic, which is
the cost to get from a node,
s, to the goal node, your s.
Now, what we don't
usually consider with A*,
but is very important for D*, is
how to distinguish between ties
when two different nodes on the
search cube have the same total
cost.
So here's what
we're doing is we're
introducing a couplet, which
consists of two values.
The first, which I'm calling
f1 here for any given state,
is the same as what
we're usually used to.
It's the linear
combination of your cost
to reach the goal node
and heuristic function.
But we also introduced
a second value
for this couplet that's used
in the case for only those
to draw.
And that is simply the
cost to go, that g value.
So the order of expansion
of nodes from the q
will order them in
terms of f1 first,
and if two nodes at
the front of the cube
tie in terms of
their f1 value, we
select the node with
the lowest g value.
So looking at our
graph down here,
we're looking at our
states s1 here and s2 here.
Can anyone tell me the
total cost for our node s1
which, remember, is a couplet
of two different values?
5, 3.
So five, yes, is
our cost to reach
this node one, plus the
heuristic, which is 2 here.
And also, 3 is our second value,
because it's only our g value
there.
And so what would the value
be by the same logic for s2
down here?
AUDIENCE: 5, 2.
BEN AYTON: 5, 2.
That's exactly right.
And so, bearing in mind
what I told you before,
where should we take
off the q first?
AUDIENCE: S2?
BEN AYTON: That's exactly right,
because the first value, f1,
for these two nodes
is exactly the same.
But the second value
is lower is f(s)2.
I'd also like to introduce
the concept of successors
and predecessors
of any given node.
In general, a graph
consists of directed edges.
And we could have a graph
with undirected edges,
but we can think of
as just any edge being
directed in both direction.
So here, we define the concept
of a successor of a node, which
is every node can be reached
from a given node, along edges
that can be found.
So the successors of
this given red node
are these two blue nodes here.
We also introduced the
concept of predecessors,
which is every node from which
that node can be reached,
meaning nodes from
which we can follow
our directed edge to our node.
So for our red node,
the predecessors
are these two nodes.
What I'd like to
emphasize here is
comparing the two,
that this node here
was both the processor and
the successor of our red node.
And that's fine.
That occurs when we have
undirected edges or edges
that direct in both directions.
So think about D* Lite in
the sense that is a repeated
best-first search, which is
where the A* principles come
in through a graph with changing
edge weights as that graph is
traversed, meaning that as
we travel from our start node
to our goal node along a
path that we are planning,
we can see that edge
weights are changing.
And in this example,
I'm modeling
an obstacle coming in place
between this node here
and the goal, which means that
we have removed that edge.
And that's effectively the same
as changing an edge weight.
We're just modeling it as
changing this edge weight
to infinity, which means that
edge can't be traveled along.
And as I mentioned
before, we also
view this as replanning through
relaxation of path costs.
So once we have
moved to this point,
how do we find
the path from here
to here when this edge has
been removed, essentially?
So we want to make
D* Lite efficient.
And it's a repeated
search through the graph
as we traverse it.
So you'll see that since we're
using these g values, if we
maintain a formulation where
we're measuring the distance
to go or to reach a node
from our start node,
this is not preserved when
we move our start node.
And we move our start
node when we're updating
the position of our vehicle.
So let me show this
through an example here.
The g value, or cost to
get from one start node
to our current node, s,
here is the combination
of these two edges.
And so, it sums to 4.
Now when we move along
that path that we've
planned to this next node, the
g value to get to that same node
is here too.
So this isn't preserved.
And that means that we'd have
to potentially reformulate
things in our cue, which
would be very inefficient.
So what we do is we
reformulate our search.
And it's perfectly valid
to reformulate our search
to search in the
opposite direction.
We're essentially measuring
for our g values now the cost
to reach the goal
from a specific.
And instead of heuristics,
then measure the costs
to get from this specific
node, or to get from the start
node to our specific node.
And so we search from the goal
backwards through the graph.
In this case, we see that
regardless of whether our start
node, we preserve our g values,
and our cost to travel from
s to that goal.
That's what we
like, and we we'll
keep that reformulation
to maximize efficiency.
So here, I want to give you a
kind of overall understanding
of the D* Lite algorithm before
we dive into specifics of what
it's doing.
First we want to initialize
all nodes as unexpanded.
And what exactly, it means
expand a node neighbor
or cover.
And then we're doing
a best-first search
from the goal node
to the start node
until the start node is
consistent with its neighbors.
And I'll again say
what that means later.
We then move our start node
to the next best vertex,
essentially our node moving
along the plan that we created.
And then we have to see if any
of those edge costs change.
We track how our heuristics
change, and then update
the source nodes of
those changed edges.
And we essentially
repeat this process
until, again, we've converged to
a solution, and we keep moving.
So this best-first search, the
A* Lite part of the algorithm,
is where most of the computation
is going to be occurring.
However, the
incremental component
is actually how can we
adjust our edge costs
to make sure that we're
using most of the information
that we previously gathered
as efficiently as possible.
So I'm going to walk you
through various steps of this.
First, I'd like to walk
you through this step
of moving to the
next best vertex,
just so you understand that.
So we can extract a
path, given the path
costs that have, through
this simple argument,
which says that we
map the successor,
by which I mean we restate
what the start node is,
because we're moving
from one state
to the next state, which
becomes the new start node,
by this form, which essentially
says that we're taking the best
path in the sense that we're
minimizing the total cost that
would be gained traveling
by that path to this node.
So in a sense, the g
value to get to this node,
to the red from the green,
or color stretching back
through the graph, by
this path here, is 7.
But to get to this node
from the lower node is 10.
And so our g value that is
optimal is 7 in this case,
and know that we pick the
successor as the green node
up here.
So now to walk through
some principles that
appear in both of these steps.
I want to show how we handle
weight changes locally.
And we do this
because we don't want
to track weight changes
throughout the entire graph.
We want to handle this
efficiently and separate them,
so we only need to
handle the changes that
really impact our problem.
So this is the same formula
that defines our successor,
or our g values
for a given node.
But we can see that
this may no longer
hold when edge weights change.
The example that I have
here is that I've changed
edge weight cost from 6 to 1.
And so now we can reach the
red node, searching back
through graph by a
new optimal path,
coming down from this node
here, which would make our new g
value five instead.
So this hasn't been preserved.
And then these changes then
propagate to our predecessors,
because the costs
for the processors
are each dependent on the g
value for their successor.
And so when we hit
a node, we have
to propagate that change all
the way back through the graph.
So to do this efficiently,
we take an A* like approach,
where we update the
lowest cost nodes first,
and we don't expand a node until
it is the next lowest cost.
To help us do this, we're
going to store additional fact.
We'll call this rhs.
Now the meaning
behind rhs, it comes
from the term right-hand side,
which in the paper world,
was first introduced and
made more sense than it
does so here.
What you can think of your
rhs value as is essentially
you're corrected your g costs.
When edge costs
change, how G should
be signed so that it's
correct for a different graph.
And when your rhs value is not
equal to your g value, that
means that we have what is
called a local inconsistency.
So given the logic that
your rhs value should
be what your g value
would be corrected to be,
what would your rhs value
be for this graph here?
AUDIENCE: 5?
BEN AYTON: 5, yes.
So this is the same graph
that I presented previously,
and I walked through
how g should be 5.
rhs should be 5 here.
And what we're tracking
is rhs and g differently.
So g is what it should be,
but we haven't got the dated g
to be 5 yet.
So we have two different
types of local consistencies
that we distinguish between.
We have what we call local
overconsistency, where g
is greater than your rhs value.
This is going to
behave more similarly
to Dijkstra's algorithm,
where the value that we're
associating to any
given node now is higher
than it should be, and
we're relaxing down
to the true value.
However, we have a lovely
underconsistent case
that we have to handle
slightly differently.
So now I'm going to walk through
updating and expanding nodes.
What I mean by updating a node
is recomputing the rhs value,
and then placing that node
on the priority queue,
if that node is
locally inconsistent.
So to give an example here,
I've changed this value,
moving from 6 at
the bottom to 1,
and recomputing rhs,
as we did beforehand.
Now we see that the node
is locally inconsistent.
In this case, it's
locally underconsistent.
And so we place that
on the priority queue.
The priority queue values are
based on this new formula.
This new formula essentially
handles how we see G and rhs.
In essence, we want to take the
minimum value of one of these,
so that we can handle it
the first time that it
will cause changes that
propagate through the graph.
And so this is essentially our
ordering on our priority queue
which is essentially the same
coupling that we saw for A*.
But here, we just
have g of s replaced
by the minimum of g
of s and rhs of s.
And so, here your
minimum of g and rhs
is 5, plus a heuristic, leads
to a total cost associated
with this node of 9, 5.
So we expand our
five prior nodes
by then taking them off the
priority queue and changing g.
Now I said here that we
have an inconsistent.
And so, we update this in much
the way that we would expect.
Your g values are relaxing
down to your rhs values,
and so we just set g
to be equal to rhs.
In this case, our node is
now locally consistent,
and it's going to stay that way.
So can anyone think
of some good reasons
why I go through the process
of changing rhs and keeping
track of that new value,
only to put on the queue,
and then take it
off again, instead
of just recomputing what g of
s should be in the first place?
Does anyone have any ideas?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BEN AYTON: What you can
think of is that you're
putting something on the queue.
If we update that
value immediately,
there are multiple nodes that
could change the same node
that we just considered.
By, which I mean more work
changes as they propagate back
through the graph,
could lead to changes
in rhs value of
that specific node.
And so, what we would need to
do if we can recompute g of s
every time, is put
it on the queue
to signal that we're
recomputing g of s,
and do that recomputation, and
then new changes we've done,
perform that again, do
that again and again
and again and again.
And we want to avoid
that situation.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to keep our rhs
as essentially a temp
value that can be adjusted
when it's in the queue.
So when something is on the
queue, it's on there once,
and it can be updated
and taken off.
But we know when
it's been taken off,
that it's been taken
for the correct time,
and won't need to
be handled again.
AUDIENCE: So if I
understand this correctly,
so if you had a single
edge cost that we changed,
then you could just do what
you just said, in terms of,
you could just update
the thing, and probably
should be predecessor rate.
BEN AYTON: Yes.
So if you knew for sure
that nothing else was coming
back and down,
then we could just
do that change and propagate
to all the predecessors,
because nothing upstream
of that node is affected.
AUDIENCE: So am I
understanding correctly--
so you're basically running
the programming, because you're
keeping the costs
to goal to devote,
and then what you're doing
is every time you have
an edge that changes to a value
that could potentially make
that node better
than it was before,
so if it changes the value
of that node to something
better than it was before,
you would change that node,
and then queue all
the predecessors,
because those be
changed as well.
BEN AYTON: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I mean, if
those nodes do not change,
you don't do anything.
You're moving from the queue.
They also change a
better bell and keep
propagating until you have
nothing else to [INAUDIBLE]..
BEN AYTON: Yeah.
But we only do the
propagation, or we
queue changes that occur
earlier in the graph,
but we only actually
perform the change
resetting the g value,
when it's expanded.
AUDIENCE: And then
the reason for that
is for efficiency when you have
more than one edge changing?
BEN AYTON: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So you could basically
have multiple paths affecting
the same node.
And in this situation,
if you actually
allow your changes will
occur and multiple edges,
that's when the importance
of the queue comes.
BEN AYTON: That's exactly.
AUDIENCE: Which is
actually, it prevents you
from redoing the same
work over and over again.
BEN AYTON: That's exactly right.
Because if another
change came through,
then we'd put all the
predecessors back in the queue
again, and we'd do all of
our updates for all of them
as well.
We're avoiding that process.
AUDIENCE: And the queue ensures
that we're only updating--
and I think that'll cover it.
But in the manner in
which we terminate,
we don't necessarily-- we don't
expand every node in the queue.
We only expand those we need
in order to find the shortest,
and then we retain the queue
for that search in case
we need to update those in
the next round of the search.
BEN AYTON: Right.
So I have to correct a
mistake in my language
that I said before.
I said that the node in my
examples that I gave before
was highly consistent,
[INAUDIBLE] wasn't consistent.
I apologize for that mistake.
Other consistency is the easy
case that we're handling here,
where when we expand that
node, we have to take g of s
and set that to be equal to
the rhs value for expansion.
And then we
propagate that effect
to all of the predecessors
at that point,
which means we update
the predecessors
and put those on the queue if
it hasn't had an impact on them.
This means that the node is
not low key inconsistent,
and it's going to remain
that way in that fashion.
The underconsistent
case, which was
the opposite of what I showed,
is the more difficult case.
In this case, the old
path cost was better
than the new rhs value.
Rhs value has increased
to above [INAUDIBLE]..
In this case, we can no longer
relax down to that g value
from our Dijkstra's
algorithm respective.
So we have to think of a
new way to handle this.
What we do is we
essentially set our g value
to be equal to infinity.
And this is an extra
step that's going
to cause the node to go back on
the queue an additional time.
But what this mechanism assures
is that that node goes back
on the queue at most
one additional time,
which means that for D* Lite,
we only ever examine any node
at most twice on the queue.
Once we've set g of s
to be equal to infinity,
then we can
essentially relax down
to the rhs value from the
perspective that we had before.
So we set g of s to
be equal to infinity,
and we update all
the predecessors of s
and s itself this time.
As I was saying before, we
need to put that node node back
on the cue so that
we handle it when
rhs has hit its minimal value.
And this means that
that node is now
going to locally consistent
or overconsistent.
And we handle
overconsistency in the case
that I've shown you before.
So to give you an idea of
how exactly this works,
I'm showing you an example here.
We start off with this graph,
and we introduce two changes.
We have increased
this edge cost to 5.
And so rhs has now
increased to a total of 10.
But I've also changed
a value here for edges
that you can't can see.
But assume that the rhs value
of this node has also changed.
So now we can put
all of these nodes
on a cable ordered in this
way, computed using the formula
that we've seen for it.
We expand the node s1 first.
And because it's
underconsistent,
we set g to be
equal to infinity.
Then we propagate to all
predecessors and s1 itself,
meaning those go
back on the queue.
Now, assuming that node
changes of any relevance
happen in these nodes,
we recompute the costs
for s1, which has now
changed to 14, 10,
because we're using the
minimum of infinity and 10,
which is 10 plus 14,
going behind the node s2.
Next, we expand this node s2.
And because that was
an overconsistent case,
we can just set g to be
equal to our rhs value.
We then have to propagate that
to its predecessors, which
includes s1, which has
updated its rhs value.
So if we didn't do
this, we wouldn't have
handled this effect correctly.
When we set our rhs
value here, we then
have to put this node
back on the queue.
So previously, s1 was
already on the queue,
but the effect has to be
propagated to this node, which
puts it on the
queue again, which
would mean adjusting
the values, because rhs
has been reduced by 1.
Both the costs here
have been reduced by 1.
Then we expand that node.
We have an overconsistent case.
We're setting g to
be equal to rhs.
And finally, we've completed
our graph search problem.
So now what we have to handle
is an additional complication
that occurs between
several steps,
tracking how our
heuristics have changed.
So we want to carry
over prior queue, which
was what was
mentioned previously,
between our different searches
as our stock node moves.
But the problem is that we're
moving from our start node
to a different point.
Recall that our heuristic value
is measured from any given
node to the stock node.
So when our stock
node has changed,
the heuristic value is not
going to be the same value
to the new stock mode.
So we want what's
already on the queue
to be comparable to
what is being computed
for our new value, so we can
use the math and the algebra
that we've already done.
So how we handle this is we
introduce something called
the key modifier, where we
move from the previous start
node, which here I indicated as
s last, to the new start node,
all the heuristics for
admissible heuristic
are lowered by at most a
heuristic from the last start
node to the new start node.
So now, when we add
new nodes to the queue,
instead of subtracting that
value from everything that's
already on the queue,
what we do is we
just increase for
all nodes that we
put on the queue, their
values, by this new modifier.
Because essentially when
we're taking off of the queue,
all that matters is the relative
differences between the two.
And so, instead of subtracting
a value from everything
on the queue, adding that
value to all new values that
occur on the queue will
achieve the same purpose.
And so our key modifier
is initialized to 0
at the start of the algorithm,
and is increased every time
that we update our
start by this new value,
by the heuristic
between the last start
node and the new start node.
And then we update
our total cost
to include the edition
of the key modifier
fire for our f1 term.
So now we've covered all of
the D* Lite algorithm basics.
And we can actually
walk through the slide
that I showed you
before with the math.
So when we start, we
initialize all of our g values
to be equal to infinity,
and all of our rhs
values to be equal to infinity,
except at the goal node.
And that's to ensure that
we always have a node
to start from our search.
We best-first search from the
goal node to the start node
until that's locally
consistent and expanded.
We should now know
what that means.
And that signal that we
have found our best path,
we move according to
our movement rule,
and then if any of our
edge costs have changed,
we update our key modifier,
and update our rhs and queue
positions for the source
nodes of change in edge costs,
meaning the nodes from which
those edges originated.
And then, we simply
repeat from two,
following best-first
through the principles
that I've walked you
through for overconsistent
and underconsistent nodes.
And as a reminder
down here, we always
search or sort by this very
long couplet of two values.
So now, we're going to
walk through an example
of [INAUDIBLE].
JESS NOSS: OK.
So again, here's the pseudo code
that Ben was just presenting.
And we're going to go through a
quick example with five nodes,
so this isn't going to show all
of the properties of why you
would want to use
incremental path planning,
because when you
have only five nodes,
you're going to end updating a
lot of them a lot of the time.
But after the
example, you'll see
how it makes more of a
difference on a larger graph.
So in this graph,
we're going to have
prior nodes that go A, B, C,
D, and G is our goal node.
The robot will start
at node A, and its goal
is to find the shortest
path to node G,
except that the
graph might change
as the robot goes
through, or the robot
might gain new information.
So initially, the robot thinks
that every node is available.
And it knows that the
path lengths are all 1,
except for from D to G,
the path length is 10.
So this is a
bi-directional graph.
Every edge goes both directions.
And the heuristic,
as Ben described,
will be with respect
to the start node.
In this case, we'll just
say that the heuristic
is the number of nodes
to the start node.
So we're ignoring the fact
that this edge length is 10.
So first, we'll initialize
all the g and rhs values.
So we have infinity
at every node,
except for the goal node,
which has an rhs value of 0.
So this means that
all of the nodes
are correctly
locally consistent,
because their g and rhs values
are the same, except the goal
node.
So we put the goal
node on the queue
using the formula that
is on Ben's slide, which
I'll put here for reference.
So the key is going
to be these two terms.
First, we have the
minimum of g and rhs
plus the heuristic value
plus the key modifier, which
is initially 0.
And then we have the
second term, which
is just the minimum, g of rhs.
So you can see how we
would get 3, 0 here,
because the 3 comes
from the heuristic,
and everything else was 0, so
we just added a bunch of 0's.
So that's everything what
happens for the initialization.
And now we have one
node on the queue.
So we'll have to dequeue first.
This is an easy question.
AUDIENCE: The node on the queue.
JESS NOSS: The one
node on the queue.
So we dequeue G. So we're going
out to update its g value.
So as Ben said, the rhs value
is sort of a look ahead.
You can also think of rhs as
being the shortest path that we
found so far, and G is the
guaranteed shortest path
to that node.
So this one is trivial.
The shortest path from
this node to itself
has length 0, because
its the same node.
So now we're going to update the
rhs values and its neighbors.
So it has two neighbors,
C and D, and in each case,
the rhs value will
be the minimum--
this is not actual math, but its
the minimum of the edge cost,
the d value of a neighbor
plus the edge cost.
Which is the same thing as the
edge weight or the weight w.
So we rhs is 10 here, because
it's the distance from g to do,
and then it's one,
which is G to C.
So again, we can
calculate keys for those.
So now we'll dequeue
another node.
What should we dequeue next?
AUDIENCE: C.
JESS NOSS: C. Because
it has a smaller key.
So we dequeue C. We
update its g value.
So this is saying, now we know
that the shortest path to C
actually has length 1.
And we can also compare this
to A* star algorithm by drawing
a search tree.
So in the beginning, we had A*.
In the beginning,
we just had node G,
because we were searching from
G backward through the goal.
And then we expanded
that back to get C and D.
And then A* to keep track of the
path length to that node plus
the heuristic at each node.
So the pathway to C was
1 plus the heuristic 2,
give us the value of 3.
So if we go back a
moment, we can see--
is that OK?
So you can see that this 3 is
the same as the first point
of the key, and path
length one is the same
as the second part of the key.
And then similarly at D, we
have the path length, which
is 10, plus the 2, give us 12.
So this 12 is the 12 here, and
then the 10 is the path length.
And so you can see how if
we were doing this the A*,
you would also dequeue C next.
OK.
So now, we dequeue
C, and we're going
to update the rhs
and its neighbors.
So B is pretty simple.
Previously, it's
rhs was infinity.
Now the shortest path to
B that we've found so far
has length 2.
So here we have B was a path
length 2, plus a heuristic of 1
gives us 3.
But what about D?
Previously, its
rhs value was 10,
but do we now have
a shorter path to D,
given that we're expanding C?
Or is 10 still
the shortest path?
AUDIENCE: That is the
shortest path, through C.
JESS NOSS: Yeah.
So now that we're
expanding C, we
see that you can actually get
to D in only two units instead
of 10 units.
So that's better.
So we'll update
the rhs value to 2.
And that means that we're going
to change D's key accordingly.
And the way that maps to A* is,
so if you already have the path
length is 2, plus the
heuristic is 2, gives us 4.
And the fact that we're
changing the key to 4,
2 means that we're never
going to expand this D,
because A* uses an extended set,
so it would always expand this
D with a shorter
cost before this one.
So that's indicated
by-- removed by changing
the key on the queue.
So what do we do next?
Which node do we dequeue?
AUDIENCE: B.
JESS NOSS: B?
Yeah, because it
has the smaller key.
So we'll dequeue B. We'll update
its g value, which is again
saying that we know now that
the shortest path to B is 2.
So we dequeue B, and
then we expand it.
How many neighbors does B have?
AUDIENCE: Three.
JESS NOSS: Three.
So we're actually expanding to
all three of those neighbors.
We have A, C, and D.
Can we still see this?
We can.
So at A, it's pretty simple.
We have the rhs value is 3,
because it's the shortest
path through GCB to A. So that's
3, plus the heuristic 0 plus 3.
What about-- oh, see, it
doesn't change, because--
you could go through
B and back to C, but--
oh, C shouldn't
actually be on here.
Sorry.
C shouldn't be on
here, because we
don't want a loop in our path.
OK.
So at D, can we do better
than this path length of 2?
AUDIENCE: No.
JESS NOSS: No.
Because what happened
was originally,
we had the path length
of 10 through G,
and then we had the
path length of 2, 3 C,
and this path through
B is not as good.
So we're going to keep the
same rhs value and key at D.
And we can see that in a lot
of he A*, where we would have,
if we did do GCBD, we
would have a pathway of 3,
plus the heuristic of 2 is 5.
But we would never actually
want to expand that D,
because it's not as
good as this one.
OK.
Now what would we dequeue?
Looks like we have two nodes
in our queue currently.
JOE LEAVITT: A.
JESS NOSS: A. So we
dequeue A. That's
where we trying to
get to, because that's
the current start node.
So we set the g
value to 3, which
means that that's actually
the shortest path.
And we're done.
We found the shortest path.
Well, we're done, except that
the path might have to change.
So one thing you notice
here is that we never have
to actually set D's g value.
So it's possible, maybe there's
still a shorter path to D,
but it doesn't matter.
So now the robot will move
to its next best place, which
is B, and we'll update the
heuristics accordingly,
because this is
our new start node.
So now, again, our
heuristic is the number
of nodes away from
that green node.
And we're keeping the same
items on the queue from before.
But we also have to
update the key modifier.
So now what happens is
an obstacle appears.
So there's an obstacle at
C that the robot can now
see because it's moved
closer to node C,
but it couldn't see it before.
So now, we're going to indicate
that by keeping all the edges,
but changing their
rates to infinity.
And that means that the robot
could try to get to see,
but it wouldn't ever get there.
So what we do next in
the algorithm is we're
going to update all of
the rhs values associated
with the source
nodes of these edges.
And in this case, the
edges go both directions,
so all four of these nodes are
affected by the infinities.
So let's start with node C.
What would be its new rhs value,
given that rhs is the minimum
from one of its neighbors to it
of the g plus edge cost?
AUDIENCE: Infinity.
JESS NOSS: Infinity. because
all of the edge costs going to C
are infinity.
So what would be the key?
The tricky part here
is the first part
of the key is the
minimum of g and rhs.
So the minimum of
g or rhs is what?
AUDIENCE: So it'd be 3, 1?
Yeah.
JESS NOSS: Yeah, 3, 1, because
the minimum of g and rhs
is g, which is 1.
The heuristic is 1, and
the key modifier is 1.
OK.
How about node B?
What's the new rhs value?
So it has a neighbor
here with g as infinity,
a neighbor here of g is
1, except the edge length
is infinity.
And then this guy with g is 3.
AUDIENCE: So it's infinity, 4?
JESS NOSS: 4.
Yeah, because
currently, we still
think that you can
get to A and B units.
So this is actually
going to be 4.
So this is one of the
sillier things that D* does,
but luckily, it doesn't
do this very much,
so it doesn't actually
really cost too much time.
And then how about D?
What would be the new rhs value?
AUDIENCE: 5, 3?
rhs.
JESS NOSS: So it has
been 3 neighbors.
This edge length is infinity
is useless, so that's useless.
This one has g of 0
plus 10 would be 10.
Yes, so this is the best one.
G is 2, plus edge length of 1.
So that would give us 3.
So now what do we dequeue?
AUDIENCE: C?
JESS NOSS: C. So this is one of
those tie breaking cases, where
both of them have
the first value is 3,
but C has a better
second value in its key,
so we'll dequeue C. Is this
over or under consistent?
So the definitions of
over and under consistent
that we had earlier, we had
if g is greater than rhs,
then that's
overconsistent, and we
set g equal to rhs
when we're updating g.
So that was the case
that we've seen so far.
But then if g is less than
rhs, it's underconsistent,
and we set g to infinity.
So what is this?
AUDIENCE: Underconsistent.
JESS NOSS: Underconsistent.
So the reason
intuitively why we're
going to set g to
infinity is because we're
saying there's some sort
of contradiction here.
This one doesn't make any sense.
It's less than the
rhs value, so we're
going to just reset g and sort
of start over with this node.
So we set that to infinity.
And in this case,
we don't actually
need to add the node
back onto the queue,
because it's now consistent.
It's now locally consistent.
So next, we'll dequeue the one
with the smallest key, which
is B. B is also underconsistent,
so we're going to set its g
value back to infinity.
So this is sort of resetting
the weird thing we did earlier
that didn't make any sense.
We're going to update its
neighbors' rhs values.
So what would be the
new rhs value for A,
now that we know that we
don't actually have a path B?
AUDIENCE: Infinity?
JESS NOSS: Infinity.
Yeah.
And then, how about
rhs value to D?
Because currently,
D got its rhs value
by going from A to B to D.
AUDIENCE: 10.
JESS NOSS: 10.
'Cause now the only way--
rhs is 10.
The key would have
that one also.
Is that right?
Yeah.
Because currently,
the best path to D,
and actually, the best
path to D you can see
is from G to D, because you
can't go through C anymore.
So now, we'll dequeue node A,
because it has the smallest
key.
It was also underconsistent,
so we would set G to infinity.
So we'll propagate
that to its neighbors.
And if we continue doing
this, then we find--
eventually, we dequeue this
node, and in this case,
we had to dequeue
everything, so now the node's
are locally consistent.
So what's the best path that
we've found from B to the goal?
AUDIENCE: B, D, G?
JESS NOSS: B, D,
G. And that's also
the only path in this case.
And we had to update
these neighbors.
OK.
So here's our new shortest path.
Now, the robot will
move to node D. But now,
what's going to happen--
I think we updated
our heuristics.
But now what happens is it turns
out it's a moving obstacle,
and it starts
following the robot.
So now the obstacle
has moved to there.
So as humans, we can see
that, obviously, the shortest
path is through C,
but the algorithm
doesn't know this yet.
So what would we do next?
So we just updated
our edge weights.
So now all the edges
to B are infinity.
But some of the edges to
C are no longer infinity.
So we need to update the
rhs values accordingly.
So we'll update all
of the rhs values
that were affected
by this change.
In this case, G's
rhs value never
changes because the distance
from G to itself is always 0.
And this one doesn't
change because we still
use the G value here.
OK.
So now again, we can start
dequeuing and planning
a new path, so we'll
dequeue this node.
We'll propagate
to its neighbors.
Dequeue that one.
Update the rhs values.
But in this case, we don't--
let me go back step.
So we dequeue this node,
and we update its G value,
but we don't actually need
to continue dequeuing things.
We should-- oh, this rhs
value should be updated.
Oh, it is updated.
Why is this rhs infinity?
AUDIENCE: All edges
to it are infinity.
JESS NOSS: Yeah.
All edges to it are infinity.
You can't get there.
But we don't actually have
to bother expanding B,
because we've already
found the shortest path.
So this gives you sort of a hint
at when D* might be efficient.
Because even if there were
a whole bunch of nodes
over there, I wouldn't
need to consider them,
because we found
the shortest path.
So now, the robot
can move up to C.
And let's say the obstacle
chases the robot again.
Do we need to find a new path?
No.
So intuitively, we don't,
because the obstacle's not
in the way of our
current best path.
But we can also
see algorithmically
why that's the case.
So first of all, we'll
update all of our rhs values
accordingly, because
we've changed
all of the edge weights.
But the reason algorithmically
why we don't actually
need to consider any
of these change values
is because this node has
the smallest key, which
means that this is the node
that has the shortest path to G
anyway.
It is smaller key than
all the other nodes
that are on the queue.
So dequeuing things
wouldn't actually
help us find the shorter path.
So the robot can move to the
goal, and we've succeeded.
Any questions on that?
OK.
So now then we'll
talk about sometimes
when you would want to use
incremental path planning,
other than this five node graph.
ERLEND HARBITZ: Thanks.
So as Jess said, there
are sometimes good reasons
to use incremental
path planning,
but there are also
good reasons not to
in certain circumstances.
In certain circumstances,
we can actually
formulate graph problems,
where a problem is worse
by using incremental planning.
Remember that I said that D*
Lite puts any node on the queue
at most twice.
And so we can compare that to
A*, or something like that,
that does full replanning
whenever a search occurs.
That pus every node on the
search queue at most once.
So D* Lite is most beneficial
when putting the nodes
on the queue, potentially
more than once,
leads to less nodes
being examined overall.
So here is essentially
what I just said.
So A* might perform better for
certain problems if we only
have to consider a small
amount of nodes anyway.
So putting nodes
on the graph twice
would actually lead
to more expansions.
And so, to get at an intuition
of why that might occur
if changes are close
to the start node,
I want to show you
an example here.
So here, we're actually
showing an example that's
derived from [INAUDIBLE].
So we're searching forwards
here from the start node
to the goal node.
And that's just a
different reformulation,
so don't let that
confuse you too much.
When we walk forward through
A* with a good heuristic,
we might move directly from
the start node to goal node,
and find that path.
Now, if a change occurs
somewhere upstream
of the start node,
when we replanning,
we essentially have to
replan the sections that
are beyond the change
that's occurred.
So everything that's
here, to an extent, it's
relatively insensitive
to this change.
It could occur that
we would have to take
an entirely different route.
But for the most
part, it's likely
that changes are going to
couple to our existing path
and so forth.
And so we have an
efficient search
that will just go
around from the path
that we've already
planned to our goal node.
So in this sense,
we have an example
where incremental path planning
would be very efficient.
In this case, which
is a different one,
we introduce an obstacle
very near our start node.
This means that most of our
existing path is to charge.
So where we start out from our
start node to our goal node,
we have to do a lot of
recomputation from scratch.
And so an incremental
searching algorithm
is going to have to undo all
searches that we've already
done, and then search
through almost the entirety
of the graph again.
So intuitively, in this case,
just restarting with A* from
a blank slate, which we
would search directly down
to the goal, instead of doing
reparations that would send us
in one path, would be a
better idea in this case.
So since we're powering
from the start to the goal,
in this example
that we're showing,
it's worse to use incremental
path planning algorithms
when your changes happen
near your start node.
For something like D* Lite, we
search back from the goal node
to the start node, it's
better if changes occur nearer
to the start node, which for our
vehicles that we normally see
that have limited
sensor horizons,
is what's going to
occur in the most case.
So in those type of situations,
incremental path planning
is going to be very efficient.
AUDIENCE: So I understand
how this could be a problem
for LPA* and D* Lite over
finding a single path,
where you have like a
single source or destination
or something like that.
But what if it's incremental,
all-pairs shortest-paths,
where you've computed--
I'd assume you wouldn't
experience the same problems
if your algorithm was computing
choice paths between all pairs
of nodes indirect.
ERLEND HARBITZ: Yeah.
It already exists.
Well, that depends.
When you're redoing
recomputation,
between all the
nodes in the path,
it depends if our
obstacle has changed
[INAUDIBLE] of something
there that we to conceive.
And by that I mean
imagining this graph
we've computed, D, the
paths and path costs,
to get from every single node
to every single other node.
Now, if introducing
an obstacle here
only changed the path cost
to get from our stock node
to our goal node
from example, then
replanning that specific
pair of paths from start node
to the goal node
would use data that
already exists from the
other nodes to the goal node.
We already have that.
But if introducing an
obstacle would cause changes
throughout the
entire graph, then we
can potentially
create what would
have to be a very well-connected
graph, where again,
incremental path planning
would probably perform worse
in that case.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So you could still end up in
the same situation [INAUDIBLE]..
ERLEND HARBITZ: Now
these algorithms
are interesting, because they
allow for some extensions that
allow us to do some some very
different things quite easily.
One example is greedy
mapping, in terms
of how can we design
algorithm using
what we know about
incremental path planning,
to hit every single
node on our graph.
And what we do is then we
introduce a faux goal node,
essentially a node that doesn't
exist that we can never reach.
And we add to our
initial beliefs,
our initial understanding
of the graph
connections between all
nodes to this faux goal node.
Now, it's false in the sense
that whenever we move our start
node to one of the nodes
that we've examined before,
what happens in terms of
the changes of the edge
costs is removing that edge that
connected that node to the goal
node.
So what this means
in principle is
that our vehicle,
our poor vehicle,
can never reach the goal node.
Whenever it reaches
a node that it
thinks it can get to
the goal node from,
that path disappears.
But what that causes it to
do is when it's replanning,
it finds a path to a node that
we haven't visited before,
because it thinks there is a
path that leads from that node
to the goal node.
And so this means
that it's efficient,
but replanning a root from his
current understanding to a node
that it hasn't examined before.
And so it can apply something
like the D* Lite or LPA* with
this formalism in order to
search through the graph in its
entirety and make sure that in
a greedily efficient manner,
we hit every single
node in the graph.
AUDIENCE: Is this
[INAUDIBLE] TSP
problem, or the traveling
solutions problem?
ERLEND HARBITZ: I'm not very
familiar with the TSP problem.
AUDIENCE: You try to--
and you try to cover
all the Cs, and try
to come up with a route
that is the most efficient,
and try to visit every
known C value once.
ERLEND HARBITZ: OK.
Then in that case, yes.
It's not going to be
globally efficient.
As you said, it's going to
be an approximation for it.
In a sense, from each
node that you visited,
you're searching for
the next best choice.
So it's possible you
can corner yourself.
But it's a way that we use
what we already implemented
and the methods
that we've already
established to tackle a
different type of problem.
AUDIENCE: And all this
[INAUDIBLE] usually if
you have a strategy which is
visit the closest unvisited
node, instead of making
this whole incremental path
from this study.
If your policy is, always move
to the closest unvisited node,
how worse does that
get compared to this?
ERLEND HARBITZ: I think it
would behave quite similarly.
What we're just
trying to show here
is that we can implement
that problem as an extension
if this happened.
It may be an efficient
way to do it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
probably like, zigzag.
ERLEND HARBITZ:
Also, if you're just
going to the nearest
connected node,
if you corner yourself
as we showed here,
then you could potentially
run into issues
if your algorithm doesn't then
do an extended search for it.
If it only considers nodes
in its immediate neighborhood
that hasn't visited,
once it corners itself
and doesn't know where to go.
AUDIENCE: Just keep
going through the graph
until you hit the
next inhibited node,
assuming that you know how many
invocations you have to do.
AUDIENCE: Sort of like the
random walk type approach?
AUDIENCE: Well, I mean, kind of
like the greedy version of it.
You kind of start
from a node, and then
you keep searching,
you'll see, what
is the next unvisited
node, and you pick that.
Kind of like--
[INAUDIBLE] some you see
what you have covered.
You see what's the
next best move.
You make that move.
And you're done.
[INAUDIBLE] So you probably
don't have this [INAUDIBLE]..
ERLEND HARBITZ: This
basically ensures
you're going to find
the shortest path back
to the next unvisited
node, I guess.
We also can use these
incremental path
planning algorithms
for anytime planners.
And the benefit of
an anytime planner
is that we quickly reach a
plan which is suboptimal.
And then from there, we
are repairing this plan
to approach optimality.
And this is useful
in the real world
where you want to get a
solution that comes out quickly,
and we want to start
along our solution,
and then repair it as we go.
And once we start it, we
need o save some more time
if your reparations might lead
to small changes and that type
of thing.
And this can be handled
quite efficiently
using an incremental
path planning.
So what happens is we apply
something, idea, called
inflated heuristics.
And so these inflated
heuristics are essentially
increasing our
heuristic values that
exist on our graph,
in our true graph,
by a cost of scale factor.
And this is
typically very large,
so differences in heuristics
become very large.
This means that once
we start along a path,
we continue along it.
And that causes us to very
quickly find the first path
that actually works.
Then, we can view reducing
those heuristics back
to their original values as
essentially a form of changing
our [INAUDIBLE] causes or--
so it's a form of replanning.
And then by applying
the principles
of an incremental planner, we
can efficiently use the data
that we already have in
order to perform the search
and repair our
solution as we go.
Finally, we want to
make explicit to you
guys how we can actually
apply these algorithms
to mobile robotics.
Because it may not
immediately clear how
we go from a full
space to a graph.
Joe on this kind of briefly
when he talked about we
discretize the world.
But we want to give you
guys some ideas of how
we might do this cleverly.
So in order to build a graph
system out of our world state,
we differentiate between
holonomic systems
and nonholonomic systems,
which their difference is just
in terms of whether your
constraints are differential
in nature or not.
Then we are going to
outline three methods here
very briefly, cell
decomposition,
using a visibility graph, and
sampling-based construction
methods.
So for cell
decomposition methods,
we might to do what you would
expect, take the free space
in this region and split it up
into various different cells.
And each of those cells
is going to represent
a node in our graph.
And how we can do this
is we split the region up
based on each of the
vertices of obstacles.
So we draw a line vertically
from each of our vertices
that goes in the direction
away from the obstacle.
So at the top here, it's going
up and out of the obstacle.
But in the lower left corner
there, both up and down,
don't intercept the obstacles.
We draw them in its entirely.
So we can continue this
throughout the entirety
of the state space,
and then we can
attribute to each
essential cell that we've
defined through these regions,
a single point that represents
the midpoint of that cell,
which is going to be our graph
node, because we attribute
a single set of coordinates
to each of our graph nodes.
And we also, to make
sure that our transitions
between these cells
are consistent,
additional nodes at the
midpoint of each of these lines
that we've drawn, where we make
the distinction that from here,
we've actually drawn two lines.
So we draw the midpoint
between all of those.
This allows us to
essentially create a graph
through the entire system,
and we connect each node
at the center of any
given cell to nodes
that are on the boundary
of any given cell.
This allows us to create a
full graph through the system,
that we can move
through, guaranteeing
that none of these paths,
if we follow them exactly
collide with the obstacles.
Now, this works in environments
where the obstacles are
2D polygons, and the path is
far from optimal, as we can see,
but we can plan an optimal
path over the graph
that we have defined.
And this only works
on holonomic systems.
We can also define what
is called a visibility
graph, where we essentially
draw a boundary between both
our vehicle down there
at that bottom left,
and boundaries
around our obstacles.
These boundaries are
sufficiently sized
so that if the center of the
vehicle that we're defining
is along the extended
edge of the obstacle,
that the vehicle will not
collide with that obstacle.
Then for each of the vertices
of the extended boundary
that we've defined,
we add in a new node,
and we draw all lines
between all nodes, which
can be connected
without intersecting
the extended obstacles,
which we've drawn here.
And this leads to a graph
that we can, again, plan over.
This, again, works
in environments where
the obstacles are 2D polygons.
But what's nice
about this system is
that we do get an
optimal path, provided
that we assume that we
assume that our extension
of the robot itself is valid,
or doesn't act too much--
isn't too excessive
for constraint.
Finally, going back to some
of the random sampling methods
that we mentioned at the very
beginning of this lecture,
we've introduced sampling-based
roadmap construction, wherein
we choose nodes randomly
or deterministically
throughout our environment.
The difference here,
though, is that we then
create a graph out
of this system,
and that we reason over
that graph using something
like an incremental
planning algorithm.
And so when we create that
graph, after we've sampled,
we can use the [INAUDIBLE]
neighbors of each node,
or we can connect each
node to every node
within a certain radius, which
is what we've drawn here.
Finally, in order to
actually move between nodes,
we need to have some
knowledge about the dynamics
of the vehicle, which is
what we're discussing here.
And one method that we can do
this for nonholonomic systems
is we can distinguish
between different paths that
use turning right, turning
left, and traveling
in straight lines.
It turns out that the shortest
path between two points
can be defined using
one of these systems.
And so we just have to search
over a finite number of options
in order to find the best path
that can connect any two nodes.
Hopefully, that has
given you some intuition
into how we can apply these
incremental path planning
[INAUDIBLE] systems.
Are there any questions?
[APPLAUSE]